ich bin seit Jahren riesiger Porsche Fan
und habe mir deswegen jetzt den
günstigsten 992 GT3 Deutschlands gekauft
zwar kein normalen 992 GT3 sondern
einfach unfalten den wir hier auf tiktok
und auf YouTube in den nächsten Videos
wieder aufbauen aber was ist eigentlich
so von außen kaputt erstmal ganz
grundsätzlich sehr gut carbonhube und
Carbon Daach sind ganz Frontschürze der
Lufteinlass und hier vorne diese Blende
die dran ist ist kaputt dann geht's
weiter h haben wir ein paar
Kleinigkeiten wie dieses Licht wir haben
großen Seitenschaden die Tür ist Fritte
die Scheibe also Fahrerscheibe und hier
unten der Schweller glücklicherweise ist
dort am Rahmen nichts dann geht's hier
weiter hinter ist alles okay Rückleuchte
Heckschürze hier unten dieses Ding der
Diffusor die Abgasanlage der Spoiler das
ducktail also im Prinzip ist eigentlich
an dem Auto alles kaputt